a good nap position is like I'm a huge
mad lover I love taking naps everyone
does I don't nap ever because I end up
sleeping for at least five hours I have
to be in the perfect position in order
for me to fall asleep it's not hard to
fall asleep fell in the couch I'll be
dead I can't know if like this like if
I'm in a car with this I also can nap if
it's too claustrophobic and I feel like
I can't breathe Wow whoa it's like a
beanbag well it looks like a submarine
helmet off the bat this is gigantic this
thing looks ridiculous it looks like I'm
about to like rob a bank what do you put
your face how do I do it thank you
I'm assuming this sides the front so you
can leap poke out I think yeah would
hold up is that you put your hands in
here it already sucks for people with
glasses we have to keep taking it on and
off how do I look I don't like it I
don't like having my head so warm who
sleeps like this but it is making me
fall asleep already because I feel very
soon it is comfortable
yeah people where like I'm s when they
sleep this covers your eyes so it's like
dark but then when you let your head
down you bump your nose nope nope it's
like a little dark you know it looks
like I have a turkey on my head it's
like a beanbag chair for your head yeah
I don't know if I saw someone walking
around with this I would think they're
weird it feels like I'm getting arrested
oh my god 80 bucks I'm gonna squid no
this is kind of okay and I feel like I'm
kissing the table every time I forget I
don't think I'll ever buy this and looks
funny Oh dad this isn't it I feel like
I've always been happy
my maps and this might help me full ask
my maps and really just take it up to
the next level who created this who
thought this is good be a good idea in
the words of Taylor Swift the haters are
gonna hate hate you know if you feel
good in this who cares what any people
are thinking you're saying like that
this is definitely more lightweight you
could definitely stick this in your
backpack if you're traveling I don't
understand how you would use it I hope
nothing ever break this thanks for your
head oh it looks like it would be fun
for the first five seconds and then like
my arms gonna numb this one's not as
comfortable that's nice oh yeah this is
great okay this is how I sleep on the
plane
this one just feels like it's cheap
version I'm gonna nap I'm gonna go boss
the wall you're not gonna like
half-assed this [ __ ] I just don't see
involving my hand but sleeping they use
keep my hands next to me this is more
suited for the kind of position they
have when I sleep materials so thought
it feels like you're already in another
dimension it doesn't feel as comfortable
as the other one I like this one so much
more it's just so bright now still if
someone comes and kidnaps me I won't
know I just won't like be able to take
it off fast enough to like react but
this like you just open your eyes yeah
definitely like this one more